best way to describe the millennial
generation and I think it's full of
passion and excitement and uniqueness
people carving their own their own paths
and their own way of doing things I
think that's pretty special
millennial is fearless I don't really
find myself using the word millennial I
think it's one of those words that non
militant Millennials use to describe
Millennials I love it I think it's so
exciting that we have such opportunities
at such young ages to make a difference
in the world and have our voices heard
and have our ideas brought to life
Millennials can sometimes get a bad rap
because we're naive and overconfident
and you have to be a little bit cocky to
be willing to take the kind of risks
necessary to actually create positive
change in the world Millennials have
insane access to information and you can
really become passionate about something
and learn a lot about it and then go
after a goal the most encouraging aspect
of Millennials is that they need to see
things to believe it and that they want
to test things and they want to really
evaluate it for themselves I think that
Millennials are ready to go out and find
their path more than any other
generation and they want to change the
world
it's a very very unique generation in
the sense that we are we have some kind
of hope for a better future which is
always good but in terms of anything
special oh we're all the same